- 297 drafts.
- It used to be like 5,000.
- [Woman Wearing Scarf} My Goodness.
- [Narrator] So today we
are going to be ranking
on screen time.
- Ooh.
- Okay.
- [Narrator] How's
everyone feel about that?
- Interesting.
- All right.
- I be on my phone a lot so.
(upbeat music)
- The exact opposite.
- Really.
- Okay.
- Like
- [Man On Far Left} I'm Up Front.
- No
- I put myself at the front.
- I put you in the front.
- I put myself in the front.
- I put you at number 2.
- Me?
- I think you.
- And I feel like you'd
be towards the front, too.
- I feel like you'd be in front of me.
- But I feel like I'd
also be towards the front.
- [Joaquin] You think so?
- But then
- I'm not last.
- A middle man.
- [Alaa] I think you'd be a middle man.
- And I think you'd be number 2.
- I think you would be 2.
- I think, yeah.
- Okay
- Okay.
- And then you're behind
me or in front of me?
- No, I think in front
of you but behind her.
- Okay. I think this is solid.
- This is, yeah.
I feel like, yeah, I feel good about this.
- Yeah. Sure.
- [Narrator] What visual
cues are you going off of?
- I don't know.
I was looking at outfits and stuff.
- Me too.
- Aesthetics.
- Vibes.
- Yeah.
- I would definitely put him first.
Just get the feeling.
(upbeat music)
- I do like, my name's Joaquin.
I do fashion.
I do like fashion inspo.
I like say where I'm from, how tall I am.
And then like I post stuff like this,
it's just like styling a certain thing,
you know what I mean?
So like, I'll style these sweatpants
and then I'll show like 3
or 4 outfits from those.
- That definitely takes a while to edit.
- Sure. Definitely.
- This is my Instagram.
I don't really post that much.
I do like stories every once in a while,
but I have like one post
- Okay.
- from my trip this summer.
And then my TikTok
- 297 drafts.
- It used to be like 5,000.
- [Alaa] My goodness.
- See, I post a lot of
stories about like TV shows
- Okay.
And fan fiction and just
like my life, you know?
- Okay.
- I talk a lot about heart stopper,
just like what I wear.
- This is my Instagram.
It's got me in like a ski mask.
- And TikTok.
- Your TikTok.
- I got like a following
because I did like rap music content.
- Okay. Like you rapping?
- No, no.
- Or you like saying, rapping the songs.
- No, it's like I did a tournament.
- Oh, okay.
This is me,
I actually post 'cause like
the way I think is like,
this is me.
So like I post for myself
more than anyone else.
And then I do have highlights
and then I use my stories a lot.
I have so much fun.
This is Disney and then
last night was Universal.
No, it was crazy.
It was actually insane.
- I would put you further
down the line maybe.
- Yeah.
- Just 'cause like she doesn't use TikTok
and like doesn't really use Snapchat.
- I would move in, but I
would also move you back.
- Yeah, I agree.
- I would put him in
front of me definitely.
- Okay. Yes.
- I feel like even if you don't post,
do you talk to your
friends on social media?
- I just talk to them through
messages and FaceTime mostly.
- Okay.
- I'm gonna switch with you.
- I feel like that seems more right to me.
- I'm just talking to friends.
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- I was just thinking about it again
because you just, I asked
you about like texting.
- Right.
- And you said you texted on messages.
- Yeah.
- But she posts a lot on her stories,
so I feel like you guys should switch.
Yeah.
Because even though you
don't like post post,
like stories takes time.
- You have to like,
- Like you have to take out your phone.
- If you're reposting a lot,
you have to be scrolling a lot.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- Wow. Solid. Solid.
- I didn't think of it like that.
I was just thinking of her posting.
- Yeah.
- But yeah.
For me, I go through like ups and downs.
So sometimes I'll be
like, yeah, let's go post.
Like, you saw my story.
I go crazy,
but that's because I'm posting
'cause I'm enjoying what I'm doing.
And I'm 100% that friend
that's like I have to take a picture.
Like, you have to stand right here.
- Yeah.
- We're taking this
and we're gonna show
this to our future kids.
- Capture the moment.
- Yes.
That's literally how I think.
- Well I have a lot of
difficulty with social media
because I'm a trans woman
and a lot of the time I just
feel like I'm not pretty enough
or I don't, I'm not skinny, and you know,
it's really difficult because
I feel like if I do post,
I have to always wear something gorgeous.
Yeah. I have a lot of ups and downs too.
Just with my self-confidence
and how I look and stuff so.
- I think you'll look great personally.
- Thank you.
- You're beautiful the way you are.
Think about it like that.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- When I'm thinking about posting anything
I'm just constantly thinking like, oh,
how will other people see it?
How will this group of people see it?
How will like, and I just
like, I overthink it.
So that's why like I don't
end up posting that much
and like, I'll like post something
and delete it an hour later.
- I think it's just like social media
is so much of a competition
that it's like the competition
constantly gets better
because everyone's trying
to make the best thing
that will get the most likes.
- I have a lot of, you know,
issues in life as everyone does.
So I use YouTube specifically a lot.
- Yeah.
- As a backbone for that.
Just to help me feel
better in my day to day,
you know?
- Can I ask you a question?
How long does like a normal
video that you watch?
- Like what kind of videos?
- Because I feel like
you might be ahead of me.
- Yeah, I was gonna say the same.
- Because I stop, I like set timers.
- [Joaquin] Oh really.
- I might actually put
you even further back.
- [Joaquin] Yeah, you
might be further then.
You might be further then.
- Okay
Then I'll move to the back.
- Alright. Okay.
- Yeah, I can definitely see that.
Although I will say, YouTube,
the thing is most of it is on my laptop
because you know, when
I get home, I swear.
- We're probably gonna switch again.
- We're gonna switch.
- Yeah, switch them 2.
- How about we, yeah. We switch.
- Okay, Me? Where do I go?
- You stay in the back.
- Go in the middle.
I'm gonna stay in the back.
- Yeah.
- Okay. And then you're gonna move in.
- Yeah, there you go.
- Wait, you're a college student, right?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- So do you have a lot of
free time to be on your phone?
- It depends on if I decide
to procrastinate or not.
Which happens often.
- Like what extracurriculars
do you guys do?
- I used to play basketball.
I don't anymore.
So like, it's mostly just
my social media stuff now.
So I'm mostly on my phone.
But yeah.
- When you make music, do you
listen to music on your phone?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Can I put him first?
- You can.
I mean, yeah, you can. We can switch.
We can switch.
- I do like a decent amount
of stuff after school.
I've got like usually a thing most days
for like a few hours and then I come home.
So like I've got a decent
amount of free time,
but not like all day.
- Crazy. Yeah.
- Then I think I'm a switch.
- Yeah.
- Because her occupation, her fun.
- I agree.
- Yeah. Right.
- What about school?
- I use it because of Canvas.
It's like the homework app.
- My school's very strict about
no phones during school so.
- Then I think me and her should switch.
- [Joaquin] I agree.
- I think so.
- Yeah, 'cause your school work would.
- But then you said they're really strict.
- Okay.
- Okay, cool.
- I feel like we're pretty
good with the ranking.
- [Joaquin] Yeah.
- I think we're good.
(suspenseful music)
- [Narrator] In fifth, we have Sabrina
with 2 hours and 33 minutes.
- That's low.
- Okay.
- Well I did expect myself
to be on the lower side
just because I don't
use my phone that often.
This week, games and
entertainment is 4 hours.
Yeah. My most used are
Instagram, Safari, archiveofourown.org
I read a lot of heart stopper fan fiction.
- [Narrator] In 4th, we have Ruby.
3 hours and 43 minutes.
- [Joaquin] Okay.
- Yesterday, an hour and a half on TikTok,
an hour on geography,
45 minutes on messages,
17 minutes on Safari.
- [Narrator] What's this geography app?
- Seterra.
One weekend I thought I had Covid
so I was not going out
so I was just inside all weekend
and I got really bored
so I just decided to like memorize
where every country is in the world.
So now I just like do that for fun.
- [Narrator] Joaquin, 6 hours
and 51 minutes, in third.
- Third.
- [Noah] Wow.
- Okay.
- [Sabrina] Oh my god.
I thought I had a lot.
- Oh my gosh.
- Most used is YouTube.
I'd be on YouTube for
4 hours and 23 minutes.
That's what it says.
But I do like, I usually like,
I'll fall asleep to YouTube videos.
So I think that's what it is.
But other than that it's TikTok.
TikTok I mostly use when I'm
awake so I'll scroll through.
- [Narrator] In second,
Noah, 8 hours and 9 minutes.
- Wow. Wow.
- Did I just finesse everyone?
- I don't know.
- How did I go from, wow.
- So I was actually surprised by this.
YouTube is my most used.
TikTok has almost 15 hours also,
Spotify is at 5 hours
and Snapchat 4 hours,
Waze 4 hours.
Twitter 3 hours and 45,
Messages, 3 hours and 40,
And Instagram was like 3 30.
But everything else was minimal.
Although I'm proud I'm not first,
I still feel like I should
probably cut down a little bit.
- [Narrator] In first, Alla,
9 hours and 20 minutes.
(gasping)
- Yo
- I felt like wow, do I
really use my phone that much,
or like should I feel bad
that I use my phone that much
because then I like, I
started thinking back
like what do I even do?
I read a lot.
So Kindle is at 10 hours and 7 minutes.
YouTube is 8 hours and 18 minutes.
I have no idea how.
Instagram is 5 hours and 48 minutes,
even though I have a one
hour time limit set for that.
Google is 4 hours and 25 minutes,
Messages, 3 hours and 22 minutes.
TikTok is 3 hours and 17 minutes,
Camera is 2 hours and 31 minutes.
Netflix is 2 hours and 21 minutes.
I started a new K-drama
last week and it was insane.
Mind blowing, 10 out of 10.
Spotify, 2 hours and 17 minutes.
Twitter an hour and 36.
That makes sense.
Crunchy roll, anime.
Disneyland 53.
My top is reading.
That's pretty good.
Mr. Creator, you were supposed to be here.
- Third. I did not think third.
- You put yourself number 1.
- I would think 2nd or 1st.
- Yeah that's 'cause I'd
be on my phone a lot.
(upbeat music)
- So people think that our
generation is like dumb
because we spend so much time
on screens and electronics
and I just have to say,
I feel like electronics and screens
have made us a lot smarter
and like open to the world
because we can just know
more about what's happening
and I feel like that leads
to a lot more knowledge,
if anything than less.
- Some of the biggest social movements
that have like ever been created
and the fact that there's
so many things happening
is because of us.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like we look back and you know,
it's crazy that those
generations did what they did
with like protests whatever it is,
without social media,
but now we're doing that
with in-person action
as well as online action, which is insane.
And we control the narrative.
We literally run it.
We run the show.
- Yeah.
- So don't forget that.
- We gonna be here for a while, too.
- We're gonna be here for a while.
We just started.
- Yeah.
- So yeah
- Don't be on your phone as much.
It's a lot more fun when you're
really living in the moment.
- Make sure you're doing what
you want on social media.
- You know, you can be on
your phone as much as you want
but you know, just maybe
tone it down a little bit.
You know, go hang out with
your family or something.
You know what I mean?